I learned how to drive when I was 11. so
my girlfriend
told me it wasn't a big deal
friends had a boyfriend and he said he
had to go in we were at a bowling alley
he said I have to go in and I have to
say something to a friend I'll be there
for four seconds and we waited and we
waited and he didn't come out and so
then the girl said sure you know how to
drive let's just drive around the
parking lot I said okay and then he
didn't come out so sure let's just drive
around the block and so he didn't come
out and I just thought well this I I'm
gonna take us out and so we went to a
drive-in to get something to drink and
we got arrested
but not exactly arrested just taken to
jail